hallo mein name ist zusätzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video ihr seht schon ich sitze zusammen
mit marxheim und wir machen was wir
machen heute wieder eine challenge aber
letztens irgendwann schon mal gemacht
haben was wir letztes gemacht habe
verdiene ich euch hier irgendwo da sind
eingeblendet und zwar haben wir jetzt
mal so gemacht dass ich eine tastatur
gespielt habe und max an der maus jetzt
switch mir das ganze allerdings wir
haben diesmal keine maut hand kennen
aber glaubt uns einfach dass einer von
uns das ding bedient einer die mauer
hier machen extra unseren armen auf
vorrücken damit ihr sehen sind dass wir
nur jeder mit einer hand um hantieren
und wir haben jetzt so gut wie ich für
fast eigene geht's um bronze gehen als
im bild uhr einpacken erklärt klick
bequem bestellt werden die bobs mal
wieder
und jetzt wartet wir brauchen die blöcke
okay ich habe richtig dumme ding
gewinnen wollen wir wie vielleicht 10 24
oder 24.000 24 35 aber auch ja ok indem
wir 5 das war richtig eng
2 dann drehten muss ein bisschen gucken
mobil zu vor uns hin bauen
eine folge wären die ersten der mitte
und hätten als erstes gold alter das war
letztmalig auch der fall aber da konnten
wir damit nicht so viel anstellen
nochmal zum bachelor und zu unserer dass
alles so gut auf die mieter vor allem im
kopfhörer drin ich habe gar nichts macht
hat irgendwie alles ich ein bisschen
mehr hat quasi das doppelte und ich war
nicht aber ich hab so drin ist ist
unbekannt spring mit dem krieg war okay
das ganze leute wollen das ganze volk
das ganze geld das ganze wird dann
wieder zurück zu renault kam das gold
lassen mitnehmen okay wir können jetzt
schon das frühstück wird und hoffen das
leben wartet schildhauer laufe langsam
wachsen die hatten schon mal dass wir
unser gefeiert
ich würde fast sagen sind besser
geworden ist besser geworden weil wir
jetzt so umschauen da agieren findet
doppelt ich dachte wir sind zwei leute
ich behandle hörst du nur eine person
warum alles zweimal das war schluss soll
ich das nur eins drückst um das thema zu
hören
ich habe angst dass vielleicht einer
kommen wir warum glas drehen bogen
wartet im bund wir brauchen bogen für
bogen jetzt könnte es auch eine
rettungsplattform wollen die es
vielleicht ganz nützlich wenn wir die
angst da fallen also spezial altkanzler
ist das wort das ist die jetzt brauchen
wir essen und gehen auf spitzenspieler
oder ihres schießen ab links links links
meine ich mit links und rechts bisschen
weiter unten bitten wir darum wie wurde
abgeschlossen ist der fall der sturz war
schon okay
scheißegal werden so bereiten wir haben
die besten items man nächstes
schlechteste warum bin ich schlecht weil
ich nicht schlecht bin kämpfen kämpfen
geh mal auf den nächsten zug immer wir
sind höchstens vierter ok jetzt ordert
ein schwert der landshuter
rettungsplattform ja natürlich ich
dachte ich dass ich weg oder so nein
nein die die habacker bis 16,1 schlag
schon durchschlagen lustlos ok alter
sehr gut sehr gut serviert grad retten
so viel holz was mache ich bin genauso
ich hab die maus genommen aber dies eine
schnelle geschwindigkeit das direkt mal
lebens gegangen ist dann wollte ich den
retten nach rechts sondern aber gut
geklappt noch mal glück perfekt gerannt
ich wollte retten vor und einander
geht's unser wehrdienstes unterwäsche
und ist einer unserer abgebaut oder ich
war halt nichts unterbett nicht ab aber
wir sind im kies
dann kriegen wir das unter die heiße
luca flug man was tut er was okay aber
er ist auch unter verbessere wie sagte
unser bett ich hab gebaut was im
gamestar noch eingebaut oder so das
komplett umgestellt ok ab dem ersten
angriff auf angriff so doll ich kann ok
wollen angreifen ja komplett
local loop man bisher so dran was fällt
dem einen uns irgendwie anzugreifen
mach schon kommt auch schon außen rum
jetzt hier gehen hier in schorsch auch
nicht nach ihm
ja wir sind drin perfekt perfekt es wäre
schon ein wasserbett guten gegner auch
die 141 was ein blöder ja wichtig egal
ob dir sagen egal wir sind unter den
letzten drei lebende wir haben nur einen
getötet lukmon alter stelle mir vor wie
gewinnen das kann nicht sein mag wir
werden das nicht gewinnen alter wir sind
einfach dritter was also gut reingepasst
was wir machen aber wir haben nur einen
wir haben ein gefühl wir haben jetzt
irgendwie umgehen als anziehen als
anziehen
wir sind schon wieder voll gekriegt ok
meisten das verdammt ok-team laut
zerstört auf beiden anna ludwig wir
nehmen es noch ein bisschen gold mit den
über das loch grant kann das gar nicht
kommentieren weil noch nie so gut
springe ich springe ich bringe hochbahn
red apa was noch ein wert abgebaut
wie kann das sein alter wie gut sind
wieder in dem blau wurde vernichtet ok
alter stelle okay zum teil porta a porta
so kommen wir jetzt in unsere base zu
rückschlag einfach schon mal los wenn
wir in unserer welt sehen weil
vielleicht erwartung steve starter kit
die sind unser bis zum ersten mal
positiv mitbekommt ich wusste gleich
dass es ein item gibt helfer zurück die
base kann ich das einschätzen
er ist runtergefallen ok erst unter
gefallen gerade das hat keine sachen wer
das sagt mir jetzt den teleporter eine
andere base wie eine perle halt da musst
du nur gut zielen das ist das problem
signalisieren die hoch so ja und dann
direkt aus schwert so ja okay wir gehen
rüber ich habe auf fertig
wie knapp alter aber halb so viel wert
wie wir sind jetzt wieder das kommt an
dem auto hast du wärst profi da haben
zwei blöcke gefehlt oder so dass wir das
für betroffene eine außerdem hast du
geworfen
du hast du jetzt erstmals der typ kommt
max a
gute combo aber okay wir gehen jetzt zu
sein welche ging es zu sein wenn wir
können gehen wir zu seinen wert
probieren müssen unser wetter zu
bestellen schon direkt wieder was nicht
passt wird er heute ist mein kind unter
tv-spot killen was heißt dass wir fallen
runter und wenn wir wieder respawn tötet
dann schon was ein und fördert renn renn
renn renn renn
wie soll ich rennen bedeuten würde
abgeordnet wurde abgebaut wir gehen
jetzt zu sein wir müssen jetzt perfekt
laufen luca keine fehler ein paar
sekunden später kommt egal jungwirth
wäre richtig gut gespielt wird zu zweit
das war es echt gut ich finde wir haben
trotzdem gut gemachter richtig gut wenn
man sich das letzte mal anschaut
beim letzten mal was halt so dass wir
dauerhaft ihnen herunter gefallen sind
als in der mitte waren und kommt nämlich
gar nicht kämpfen diesmal mit zwei
betten abgebaut da durch die zwei leute
getötet
und wir hätten wenn die ender perle gut
angekommen wäre hätten wir locker auch
noch gewonnen wenn euch das video
gefallen meine damen und herren freuen
wir uns über eine bewertung max kann
also eine beschreibung verlinkt werden